cheryl affaire du jour et personne
d'histoire dans the voice on a enfin eu
des nouvelles de mes mails rappel des
faits donc souvenez-vous la candidate
avait abandonné the voice suite à une
polémique avec des anciens tweets qui
était ressorti à propos notamment des
attentes à nice elle avait réagi à la
polémique mais ned et samedi soir dans
the voice
tf1 nous a donné de ses nouvelles et ça
a été fait de manière assez expéditive
puisque c'était le dernier prime des
auditions finales où s'opposaient tous
les candidats qui avaient passé les
auditions à la vague et comme toute
cette épreuve avait été enregistré avant
la ferme nn eh ben elle avait passé
cette épreuve et avait même été choisi
par son coach milka pour expliquer son
renvoi et comment allait être organisée
la suite des événements donc on peut
dire que tf1 était très concis où ils
ont juste enregistré une voix off de
nikos qui à aucun moment d'en mentionner
la polémique pour justifier le départ de
la candidate
ils ont juste dit ça
[Musique]
tous
ressent
[Musique]
pour leur audition finale geneva et tifa
neige et ont livré des prestations d'un
haut niveau
mais mickey avait décidé de qualifier
même la suite à son départ de l'émission
ce sont donc les trois talents qui ont
quitté l'aventuré
voilà que faire d'autre que faire la
celac service minimum montage très soft
c'est la meilleure chose que la
production devait faire si elle voulait
expédié l'histoire mais là dessus c'est
incroyable talent à l'époque avec la
sphère rozon aussi l'avait expédié en
quelques minutes dont il n'allait pas
rentrer en détail ce dans la sphère l
expliquer aux téléspectateurs
oui moi je suis extrêmement choquée a
pour moi tf1 et nico sont des amateurs
et même mika n'aurait jamais dû laisser
faire ça ils ont je vais vous expliquer
ils ont été débordés par la polémique
depuis le début et à les laver partir j
avais envie et là on a enregistré les
deux adversaires de ménage sans même
leur portrait en les humiliant allaient
elles ont été balayées avec l'émission
franchement c'est un scandale s'est
passé depuis le début c'est un fiasco
total
alors nos fans de the voice et jean-luc
la seule chose qu'on peut leur reprocher
c'est finalement pour les deux qui sont
partis et on n'a même pas vu leurs
répétitions les échanges a remis qu'à
donc c'est un peu frustrant pour elle on
l'attend pour le reste je pense qu'ils
ont géré au mieux c'est plus que
frustrant c'est totalement injuste tout
de même ses deux filles qui ont été
balayés comme ça c'était le trio de mika
elles n'avaient pas à supporter le
problème de mes neil c'est dingue qu'ils
aient fait ça c'est choquant et puis je
suis étonné que les jurés n'ont pas
réagi mais me kane batman convoi le
clairement ils se sont vus fall au grain
je pense que honnêtement il se sent
raccrochons ils ont fait comme il
pouvait partir d'un contexte qui est de
toute façon était piégé dès le départ ah
oui donc là effectivement pour les bleus
je ne parle même été expéditif je suis
bien d'accord équipe ils ont sauté les
deux candidates avec l'eau du bain comme
ça en tirant la chasse
cbg désolé on a très vite effacé et
celles qui sont pas concernées par
l'historienne l excuse moi ça s'est
passé dans leur émission il aurait pu
faire une petite séquence au moins les
coaches s'exprimer sur le sujet dire
qu'il a dû retourner